(upbeat salsa music)
- Hello, I'm Chef Esdras Ochoa,
and we're at my restaurant here
at Mexicali Taco & Company.
And today, I'm gonna show you how to make
our Cachetadas de Pollo,
AKA "Slap in the Face."
Grilled chicken on a toasted tortilla,
melted cheese,
but today we're gonna do it with a twist,
our special recipe that we do
with my friend Matt Kim and I.
So Matt Kim is one of my best friends
that we met a long time
ago in an empty parking lot
when I started selling
tacos on the street.
He shows up in his car,
I did not have a clue who this kid is,
popped up his trunk, pulls out a cooler,
and all of a sudden,
he's like the most
popular kid on the block.
This uni starts coming out.
I'd never seen uni in my life,
and that's when I was introduced to uni
for the very first time.
So we decided to put it
on everything on the menu.
We put it on tacos, on quesadillas,
but my favorite by far
was the uni on top of
our famous cachetadas.
I call it "Slap in the Face"
because it's spicy, it's crunchy.
It is in your face and it's amazing.
So to start off with
our Cachetadas de Pollo,
we are going to start off
with our all-natural corn tortillas.
We are gonna dehydrate those.
We're gonna put them on the plancha.
We're gonna sit in there
for about 5 to 10 minutes.
We're gonna go on to our Pollo Asado,
and we're gonna start
off with our marinade.
First we have California chili powder,
guajillo powder, onion powder,
garlic powder, cumin,
pepper, salt, and sugar.
So now we're gonna go on with our acidity.
So we're gonna do two portions.
For something like this,
you need about two oranges.
We need about one lime.
And we're gonna give it a nice mix.
So the acidity is very important
because it helps break
down all the ingredients
and it also combines them together.
Once it's nice and smooth,
we dunk in our chicken,
and we're gonna give it a nice rub.
For Pollo Asado in the restaurant,
we love to use chicken
thighs and chicken legs.
We find that it's the
juiciest part of the chicken,
and it's the most flavorful of all.
So we're gonna give it a
nice mix, a minute or so,
make sure it's nice and fully coated.
Then we put it in the fridge
and let it rest there.
So while that's resting
and doing its magic,
we're gonna on to our pickled onions.
Time management is so
important in the kitchen,
so we're gonna do multitask a little bit.
So we're gonna take one red onion,
cut it in half, and give it
some nice, fine julienne.
Then we're gonna add our dried oregano,
make sure you crush it very finely.
So what I like to do with my oregano,
I like to grab a good bunch
and put it in between my
hands and rub it very firmly
so it turns into powder,
and that's the best way for oregano
to do what it's supposed to do.
We're gonna a good amount of vinegar.
You could use white vinegar,
red wine vinegar, apple cider vinegar,
whatever you have at home.
Season it with salt
and that's to give it
a nice mix, a nice rub,
and again, it goes into the fridge
and let it do its magic.
So food in my family means everything.
It's the time that we all get together,
forget if we're mad at each
other, celebrate things,
and its all good moments,
good happy memories.
It's a way to remember our ancestors,
our grandma's special recipes
that are true to our family.
Mexicali, it is actually the place
where I was raised and grew up
down in Mexicali, Baja California.
I learned a lot about
hard work and dedication.
I moved to LA and I decided
that when I opened my first
restaurant or taco stand,
I was gonna name it after my hometown
of Mexicali, Baja California,
and a lot of the influence
with its cuisine,
we showcase here at the restaurant.
And I think it's proper
that we name it Mexicali.
One of the most important
parts of our cachetada
is actually our signature sauce
that goes inside, Chipotle Aioli sauce.
It sounds fancy, but it's
really just mayonnaise
with chipotle and a
little bit of seasoning.
We're gonna get our mayonnaise.
We're gonna add a good
amount of chipotle sauce.
If you like it spicy with
a with a kick the way I do,
I would add extra
chipotle peppers in there.
We're gonna add a little
bit of salt to even it out,
and we're gonna add a
good amount of lime juice.
Give it a nice whisk so
it's nice and smooth.
And if you're like me,
there's never enough heat.
Put some more of that
chipotle on your aioli.
And then, again, put it aside.
So our chicken's been marinating
about 15 to 20 minutes.
We're gonna grab our
chicken, put it on the grill.
You want to go medium on this one.
If you go too high, you're
gonna burn the outside,
and the inside is not gonna cook.
Now, it's very important when
you're grilling your chicken,
you got to flip it multiple
times back and forth.
Look for those beautiful grill
marks, for the smoke signals,
for the fire bursting
everywhere on the grill.
It's not like a steak.
Steak, you let it sit there, high heat,
flip it once, maybe, and
then it's ready to go
with chicken you have to
ready dedicate some time
and give it some care.
I usually want to get that nice char.
Oh, that looks so good.
So now the chicken is grilling,
Matt is gonna do his thing.
He's so excited.
This is what he lives for.
So he's gonna crack it open.
He's got this really
cool device that he uses,
and then he's gonna
scoop out the golden uni.
So he takes the uni,
he sits it in water to
rinse it off a little bit
and then it's ready to go.
What's so cool about Matt
is that he's just as adventurous as I am.
This guy will go rock climbing,
scuba diving, spear fishing,
all the things that I love to do
but I don't really have the guts to.
So I kind of put him to the test.
First he gets it done,
then I say, "Okay, it's
doable, let's jump on it."
So we have an amazing relationship.
We know each other very, very well,
especially when it comes to food.
So we're always eating out, hanging out,
and reminiscing, and doing
new adventures all the time.
So now everything is coming together.
We are getting very close to the end.
We're gonna grab our chicken,
take it off the heat,
and we're gonna let it rest
just as you would expect.
Set it aside for 5 to 10 minutes.
While that's doing its thing,
we're gonna grab our tostadas,
nice and dehydrated, crispy,
but we're not done yet.
We're gonna load it up
with Monterey Jack Cheese.
We're gonna put them on the grill,
and we're looking
for those beautiful, gooey, cheesy,
bubbly signs of cheese heaven.
Our cheese is doing its magical gooeyness.
We're gonna go on to our chicken.
It's been rested.
We're gonna slice it into cubes,
I would say, half an inch both ways.
I like to cut it in perfect cubes.
It's for presentation, and
it's for a really good bite.
So now it's time to put this all together.
So we're gonna load our
tostada with chicken
so each bite is as perfect as the first.
So now we're gonna go on
and dress our cachetada
with our delicious aioli sauce.
And now it's time to customize it.
This is where the Mexicali style comes in.
We're known for customization.
Every palate is different.
So finally, now it's time to
enjoy this with my friend Matt.
- What are you gonna put on it?
- The usual, everything.
I personally like to
have some chile de arbol.
It's spicy, it's smoky.
I like to put some (speaks
in foreign language),
some avocado sauce.
And I like to put a little
bit of cabbage for bite,
for a nice texture.
And then we're gonna add
some pickled red onions.
These are my absolute favorite.
I put them on everything.
And then, this is where Matt Kim comes in
and he's gonna show off his
skills with our golden uni.
And if you're gonna go with uni,
might as well go all out.
You gotta make it rain and
Matt does that very, very well.
So we're gonna load it up
with uni, just how we like it.
This brings back so much memories.
- This is the start of our friendship.
- Salud, cheers.
- Salud.
- Each bite is like ocean
meets Mexicali's streets,
each memories, fun times with Matt and I.
Ah, it is my favorite thing to eat.
The uni, the ocean, I mean,
it's your story with my story
put together on a bite, dude,
this is-
- Perfect.
- This is us man, right here.
(Matt laughs)
So we are all done.
I hope you guys love the
cachetadas as much as I do.
Try it at home.
It really is a slap in the face.
(bell dings)
- [Man] Oh yes.
- [Crowd] Oh.
- [Man] Nice, there you go.
(crowd talking indistinctly)
(upbeat salsa music)